kids really do have terrifying dreams if
you ever listen to them describe their
dreams like something out of a horror
movie
so like the other day my was again my
four-year-old had a different bad dream
and he told me about it
and he said that that in his dream he
heard something in the basement and so
he opened the door to the basement and
there was a man standing at the bottom
of the step staring up like silently not
saying anything
and I said well who was the man in the
dream I mean maybe it was uh you know
maybe it was Santa Claus or something
coming to you know try to look at try to
try to see this in a positive light
and he said well I don't know who the
man was Daddy because he didn't have a
face
and I said wow that is yeah that's
terrifying I I am scared now actually
you're spreading the bad dream to me now
I'm infected
stop talking about it keep this to
yourself